Oh
for the next five weeks I continued to
help my father apply statistics to coach
his team not surprisingly they continue
to win which changed my status in the
school dramatically
[Applause]
it was a nightmare
[Applause]
hugging hair Tousley high-fives
and as my popularity grew so did my time
along
[Music]
[Music]
hey I've been looking all over for you
do you know how popular we are we yeah I
put the word out I was helping you with
the football stats and since I'm Asian
they bought it well I'm glad you're
enjoying it you're not I was touched 82
times this afternoon
what do you mean touched not
inappropriately joyfully affectionately
a cheerleader hugged me to her bosom
that's amazing
no more high-fives I can't keep washing
my hands why are you wearing it it makes
me look better just so we're clear once
you get in I'm going home hey Charlotte
what are you doing hey everybody check
it out Jonesy
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
come on you don't know how booty
treating you because it is knocking me
boy look right
[Applause]
[Music]